henry jackman it's greg here John so
we're about to film a completely
different video and buried in the middle
of it
John had mentioned to me about what
happened with Jon Schnepp I did not know
about that I was like back from the gym
so as we're I was like oh this other
news just dropped let's film it and I
found out that Jon Schnepp had passed
away and I'm not gonna [ __ ] you guys
into thinking that like we were best
friends
but I was a big fan I would did watch
Collider heroes every week and I'm
fortunate enough to have my the last
time I ever spoke to him was hey I just
wanna let you know I'm a big fan of
Collider here as I watch you every
single week it was him and Steve
Weintraub at the Upgrade premiere and I
was just what I said to him the fact of
the matter is I've seen Schnepp like
countless times that Collider yeah at
movie screenings a couple of times in
some premieres and I I was always so shy
to talk to him it's it's the same I
could
it was the same effect I had with Dan
Merle at screen junkies I've seen Dan so
many times and occasionally can hop into
conversations with him but usually I had
to muster up a lot of courage just to do
it so many things that I admire and
respect and I love watching you I'm not
genuine fan and what chefs can
contribution to the community to the
world overall I mean he was perfect at
his job yeah like he hosted Collider
heroes he's done a lot of other things
too
oh yeah he's directed stuff I mean he's
done Metalocalypse he's made
documentaries yeah it's done he was
always great at perspective he was
always great at looking at both sides of
the argument and being an optimist too
and if he was being kind of cynical
about something he knew how to address
the counter perspective as well
technology he was great at writing that
middle ground I felt and that's why I
always loved listening to him to spare
with interviews you seem like a real
dude
oh yeah and real interested like one of
my favorite things is I'm blanking on
the name now but his show where he would
go to different comic book shops and
talk to the owners yeah that was a big
one I'm sure the amount of interest and
knowledge that he would espouse like you
know you he's really one of those guys
you see on the screen you're like ah man
I wish I could just Chum with you you
know yeah and I I've seen him so many
times I've talked to him like maybe a
small handful of times and my my biggest
regret and I was open it with a friend
about it this week when when I heard he
was on life support was I wish I hadn't
been such a [ __ ] so many times yeah
right because yeah it's like no one saw
this coming that I mean I don't I mean
maybe there were people in his family
who might have seen this coming with
some health habits I don't know I really
don't like of the spectrum I had no clue
what was going to happen
yeah kind of thing what I always wanted
to just keep on conversing with the guy
but I would just get too shy I got
bogging in my head about things and I
don't mean to make it about me or
something like that I'm just saying like
you just go she had the idea to Nerdist
to say my biggest regret is that I wish
I had more ongoing conversations with
the guy I'm just glad I got to pay him
the one compliment I was was that I
meant which is I to watch Collider
heroes every week it doesn't make any
moments precious cuz like I I never got
to really spend time or speak that much
with him but every time I did bump into
him he was always always nice at least
that was the biggest reputation he had
he was no one ever said he had a big ego
oh yeah feel like you're bumping into
some lofty guy yeah high above you you
know yeah that's like even though I
would view him that way we met when you
would talk with him you're like it's
just a dude dude right now there's a go
fund me that his wife Holly Payne has
set up my condolences go out to you and
right now they have a very expensive
medical bill and this is what the
GoFundMe is going towards so there's a
link at the description boxers
common to this as well I gotta tell you
guys
today is actually the anniversary of my
dad's death I was with my family bright
and early in the morning loved going to
church that early mom appreciate it
actually I missed the church service
what they didn't shout out my dad there
so I was like all right there you go and
you may be the mention of the Catholic
Church it is a holy shout out those like
alright okay but then I was with my
family right after and I was just
kicking it with my family guessing them
again later tonight and it's been a few
years since my dad died but I remember
that when my dad died the medical bills
were so expensive because he had been in
and out of the hospital for years so the
medical bills where and like high six
figures and I could not help but just
feel pain for my mom like you you lose
your husband the father of children and
your children and then suddenly you've
got this giant debt and then and you
have to grieve simultaneous yeah it's
like some kind of weird turbo charge
yeah for your pain so just drawing it
out and ringing you out yeah I mean
they've done pretty good on their goals
so far
they still got at the moment that were
filming this 41 and a half yeah I guess
so got a lot of money to go so any even
if it's a minor contribution would help
it all builds this is a quantity game of
how many people are willing to
participate and contribute a lot of
people do a little you know it would
really mean a lot I would love it if you
guys can go go show some support yeah
we'll miss you Jon Schnepp you were a
true inspiration and a big contribution
to how we conduct our world so thank you
thank you for everything
and
respect the privacy of the family too